nous savons comment ça va vous allez
bien aujourd'hui alors je sais j'ai
aujourd'hui la casquette parce que cause
de voile à deux cheveux pas encore coupé
donc une petite casquette pour être un
peu moins moche aujourd'hui on va se
parer d'un smartphone très très cool
j'attendais j'attendais qu'un patient
c'est celui là c'est le chiot mais vous
savez pas ce que vous avez cliqué sur la
vidéo dont vous le savez je trouve à
vous cacher c'est leur ennemi note 9
très cool très court il est là c'est un
smartphone intéressant alors vous savez
je sais pas si vous avez regardé ma
vidéo où je faisais encore paradis pour
vous aider à choisir un smartphone
shinobi fait pour vous et je vous disais
effectivement que bien là gagnent raid
me nots était le meilleur rapport
qualité prix
il y avait aussi un très grand focus
fait sur l'autonomie alors on va
regarder 6h30 note 9 reste vraiment dans
l'âme est l'idée de l'autonomie du
rapport qualité prix on a tous voir du
prix de l'écran de la performance savoir
si elle fait pour vous pour le
multimédia pour regarder des films des
séries pour jouer toussa toussa toussa
on va se regarder ça ensemble mais avant
toute chose si vous n'êtes pas un job
tombé sur mon tabouret premier pas que
je les vois avec vous dites moi en
commentaires si vous trouvez qu'à une
différence tout de suite en termes de
qualité d'image et je veux changer mais
éclairage
j'ai deux éclairages qui sont vraiment
différents alors si vous vous intéressez
à la vidéo est ci et l'éclairage vous
intéresse
la température des classes n'est pas
forcément la même ce train de faire des
réglages donc ça me semble être à peu
près pareil mais comme je filme en
flammes je me rends pas forcément compte
tout de suite d'un moniteur donc dit que
le manga en commentaire si pour vous
c'est pareil ou s'il est différent ça
c'était le premier point car un peu
technique non parce tout autre chose et
puis 2e - si vous n'êtes pas tout de
suite abonnés à la chaîne vous invite à
le faire pourquoi je suis tout vous
expliquer parce que je vous présente
tous les nouveaux smartphones mon
connecter un ordinateur tout des
produits tels qu'ils sont vraiment cool
et qui valent le coup je vous fais
également des guides d'achat pour vous
aider à choisir et notamment son chéri
gentil une vidéo ya pas longtemps c'est
savoir quel smartphone chez oh oui
acheté en 2020 je pense que geoffrey une
autre dans le courant de l'année
tellement chaud me sens produit est
tellement c'est compliqué il ya plein de
nouveautés et je vous parle aujourd'hui
du
note 9 ne joue pas dans quelques jours
de son grand frère le raid me not neuf
pros je vous parlais de plein d'autres
produits de chez tommy donc si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas à beaune et vous vous
actionnez la cloche tout savoir comme ça
c'est cool et on est une grande famille
du côté de la boîte ils rien
d'exceptionnel raid min 9
le grand classique de chez choisi par
contre un poke est vraiment très
intéressant et j'ai trouvé ça assez
drôle c'est qu'ils vous le marque ici
alors c'est écrit en anglais c'était un
petit peu dommage pour le public
francophone mais qui voulut marque avec
un accès très rapide aux applications
google que vous utilisez le plus ça
s'appelle prendre un couteau et
l'enfoncé chez huawei avec les nouveaux
smartphones de huawei qui sortent n'ont
pas accès aux plays store il ya labiale
riz et là il voulut marques comme un
argument de vente premier et christian
en anglais ça peut être un petit peu
bête mais en magasin croyez-moi ça c'est
vraiment un argument de vente et s'écrit
ici de ce côté là s'écrie l'autre côté
bon qu'ils n'ont pas écrit la mise
aurait presque pu le faire un autre cas
ça va surtout smartphone c'est que
lorsque vous faites l'installation durée
linotte neuf pros eh bien il vous
demande de choisir votre moteur de
recherche soit google soit coin tu sois
doc 2 go soit info.com alors info.com je
ne connaissais pas google bien
évidemment tout le monde connaît quand
c'est le moteur de recherche français
qui vient protéger votre vie privée mais
voyez vous avez le choix
et ça c'est plutôt bien même si
effectivement on se doute que google va
remporter quasiment la majorité des
clics le smartphone en lui même est
assez bien réussi à l'arrière vous avez
un dock a tendance à prendre des traces
de doigts je vous conseille quand même 7
venir le protéger donc c'est parce qu'il
va me déranger le plus par contre ce que
j'aime bien c'est la façon dont ils ont
intégré le capteur d'empreintes
digitales je trouve ça vraiment très
très très très malin puisqu'il vient
vraiment se fondre se planquer il est
présent mais beaucoup plus discret vous
avez une vraie belle symétrie parfaite
que vous retrouvez au niveau du
smartphone vous avez les deux caméras
ici notamment le 46e mégapixels et
l'ultra grand temps qu'ils sont
soulignés au niveau du design c'est pas
mal c'est très sympa très élégant et il
vient surtout déverrouiller extrêmement
rapidement donc ça s'est vraiment bien
sûr côté c'est un grand classique bouton
volume bouton pour venir l'allumé pour
l'éteindre votre part leur prise jack
micro vous venez le brochet ici ici vous
avez votre tiroir de cartes sim sur le
dessus l'infrarouge le micro plus
réduction bruit c'est un format qui
seront quand même bien en main moi j'ai
pas des mains très très grosse il voyage
fait pas tout de suite le tour très très
facilement mais malgré tout le format
gaza smartphones qui est léger il fait
appel
199 g il est disponible en trois
couleurs vert forêt c'est cette couleur
là il est disponible en gris de nuit
c'est celui que j'ai c'est un espèce de
double
un peu gris et en blanc polaire ici vous
avez un écran lcd avec un verre corning
gorilla glass 5 avec une diagonale de 6
points 53 pouces une résolution full hd
de 1340 par 1080 pixels à 395 pixels par
pouce
un ratio 19 points 5/9 luminosité
maximale de 450 me dit c'est pas
complètement incroyable mais une fois de
plus sur smartphone d'un peu moins de
200 euros ça fonctionnera est un
smartphone qui est certifié lutter
contre la lumière bleue qualité d'écran
qui est vraiment honnête qui pour
l'aspect multimédia ira très bien et qui
vous permettra de visionner sur netflix
sur my canal en full hd sans aucun
problème tout ce qui va être un
expérience multimédia visionnage réseaux
sociaux et bien vous sera absolument pas
du super la partie audio c'est aussi un
poids qui est extrêmement intéressant
alors on se doutera ici on est sur un
smartphone plutôt d'entrée et milieu de
gamme on va pas à voir ce qui se fait de
mieux on va pas voir des haut parleurs
stéréo on a beau parleur mono qui se
planquent bien évidemment juste ici mais
vous le voyez un gars n'est pas juste un
côté vous avez une prise jack et c'est
souvent dans les smartphones d'entrée
milieu de gamme qu'on retrouve des prix
jack puisque les constructeurs part du
principe que les personnes qui vont pas
forcément mettre beaucoup d'argent dans
leurs smartphones vont permettent donc
plus beaucoup d'argent dans un casque et
n'auront pas forcément un casque sans
fil vous suivez un peu la logique du
coup si vous avez un casque avec une
bonne vieille prise jack et ça c'est
cool pour y devenir le brancher alors
pour vous le faire très très très
simplement et très court vous allez voir
que la qualité audio comme ça elle pas
folle s'est pas complètement dingue
c'est pas là où on va voir leur spectre
très large pas là on va voir là la
meilleure qualité
néanmoins somme toute assez classique ça
marche si vous poussez un peu trop fort
ce bar tendance un petit peu a saturé
mais rien de bien étonnant sur
smartphone dans cette catégorie de
taille que d'écouter ça
japan image en montagne il ya un côté un
peu idiote qui n'a pas beaucoup de base
pas beaucoup de grave se re est parfait
la moins de 200 euros c'est complètement
normal si vous mangez pas contre un
petit casque dans votre prise jack
vous allez avoir un spectre plus large
que vous allez voir une meilleure
spatialisation c'est normal ce lieu
votre carte ça dépend aussi de la
qualité de votre casque et si vous
voulez relié à un casque sans fil vous
avez dit bluetooth 5.0 et ça ira très
très bien ça sera parfaitement bien la
sphère point de vue de l'ol sait pas
grand chose à raconter au tourne ici sur
me why aux j'attends que me wade 12
arrive pour l'instant ces ouailles aux
basé sur un android disent ça marche
bien c'est assez clair il ya pas mal de
petites fonctionnalités ce que je vous
conseille quand même tas de plus c'est à
dire dans l'affichage dans le schéma de
couleurs par défaut il est comme ça il à
côté un peu plus froid
moi ce que je vous conseille c'est de le
mettre sur chaud et pas de le laisser
comme ça parce qu'ils tirent un peu plus
sur le côté un peu violine on voit pas
forcément tête avec la colorimétrie vous
venez de mettre pas ici pas trop sur le
vert voilà vous laisser un peu plus sur
le jeune ça vient casser un peu cet
effet un peu violine la couleur n'est
pas trop froide et c'est beaucoup plus
confortable pour les yeux
le reste de l' os marche bien vous avez
pas mal de choses sur le fond les
notifications les mots de passe à
sécurité bon c'est un grand classique et
ça marche très très bien
un plan qui est aussi important qui le
différencie les autres modèles et
notamment du modèle professionnel qui
lui tourne avec un snapdragon le modèle
simple le modèle basique leurs ennemis
note 9
on a un médiathèque elio j'ai 85 vous
avez soit 3 giga de ram soit 4 gigas de
ram euros vous avez deux config 3 giga
de ram 64 giga de stockage ou 4 gigas de
ram 128 go de stockage et dans les deux
cas extensible jusqu'à 512 giga côté
performances il obtient le score sur en
tout ou 289 1299 ce qui n'est pas
complètement dingue mais ce qui n'est
pas normal une fois de plus sur un
smartphone dans cette catégorie ce qui
vient le positionner en 53e position en
dessous du samsung galaxy ace 7 et au
dessus du samsung galaxy à 51 autant
vous dire qu'il est quand même vraiment
bien classés abordons maintenant la
question de l'autonomie puisque c'est
souvent des points très importants et un
des points sur lequel ce smartphone en
tout cas ses smartphones de la gamme
renmin notes viennent vraiment en tête
et sont très très forts dans ce segment
de prix là vous avez une très grosse
batterie de 5000 20 millions perreur
c'est énorme
une fois de plus sony a mis la barre
très très haute sur la gamme raid minott
vous avez un chargeur de 22,5 soit
inclus dans la boîte donc de leur
recharge rapide ça c'est plutôt bien
vous avez de la recharge on
le sbc ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
sur les smartphones qui coûte un peu
moins de 200 euros
vous allez donc pouvoir garder votre
smartphone suffisamment longtemps deux
journées si vous l'utilisez pas trop
c'est pouvoir gratter un peu plus ça
dépend une fois de plus des usages
si vous êtes beaucoup dessus bien
évidemment ça sera moins mais ça dépend
de vous de vos usages et croyez-moi déjà
avec 5000 20 millions paire eur vous
avez de quoi faire pour toute la partie
guy hemmings aussi un smartphone qui
fera très bien la faire ça sera pas
smartphone le plus performant le plus
rapide n'est pas faire tourner travaille
dessus mais pour plein de petits jeux ça
ira parfaitement bien autre usage très
important sur les smartphones notamment
pour les partage sur les réseaux sociaux
pour faire quelques souvenirs c'est
toute la partie de la photo ici vous
avez 4 capteur à l'arrière
il ya un parti pris qui est intéressant
de la part actions mis sur toujours dans
l'idée de se dire on va mettre beaucoup
de capteurs pour offrir beaucoup de
choses il ya des choses bien d'autres un
peu moins bien mais vous allez voir dans
l'absolu c'est quand même assez
équilibré ça vous aura pas échappé à
vous avez quatre caméras l'arrière la
première ici c'est une caméra grand
angle c'est un 48 mégapixels qui ouvre à
f 1.79 c'est votre caméra principale à
côté vous avez un ultra grand angle de 8
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.2 avec un
champ de vision de 118 degré en dessous
vous avez 2 mégapixels c'est pour de la
macro tout bref 2.4 avec un poids qui
situe entre 2 à 10 centimètres tandis
que de l'autre côté vous avez une caméra
de 2 mégapixels tour f 2.4 qui est là
pour notre portrait qui est là pour les
faits évoqués pour la profondeur de
champ il s'il voulait venir filmer
jusqu'en 1080p à 30 images par seconde
c'est pas beaucoup de choix 720p 1080p
voyez bon alors ils sont pas fans la 4k
l'interface est somme toute assez
classique vous cliquez ici vous
retrouvez votre petite zone macro qui
est planqué jusque là vous venez zoomer
jusqu'à un zoom x 10 et si vous appuyez
sur un petit bouton là vous passez sur
l'ultra grand-angle tandis qu'à l'avant
vous avez une caméra de ses filles de 13
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.25 là on est
sur la caméra principale
on s'attend pas à voir des photos
complètement extraordinaire sur un
smartphone qui coûte à peine 200 euros
c'est convenable je lui ai mis un
contre-jour il n'y a aucune
stabilisation royal n'a pas résultats
dingue mais ça fera l affaire on se
rapproche ici avec le x 2 et là avec le
x 10 on veut absolument plus rien du
tout l' ultra grand-angle et quand même
beaucoup plus pâle déformant ça sera
bien pour voir quelques souvenirs mais
c'est pas complètement d'un v6 mots on
retrouve ensuite sur la caméra
principale ici on retrouve
les détails ici là c'est un peu plus
flou le froid de ce qui est intéressant
c'est que quand vous êtes sur un capteur
de 48 mégapixels ici vous allez avoir un
zoom numérique comme vous n'avez pas de
télé objectifs on va venir zoomer dans
l'image
à partir du capteur 48 mégapixels elle
résultat est somme toute assez
convenable mais dès qu'on va beaucoup
plus loin voyait que le x 10 tout de
suite voilà c'est pas terrible ultra
grand-angle et à ces moyens aussi sous
ceinturé bon voilà c'est pas ouf
problèmes de gestion des hautes lumières
qui n'est pas exceptionnel une faute sur
cette typologie de produits s'est pas
surprenant ici c'est exactement la même
chose c'est normal faut disent pas
terrible ultra grand-angle s'est cramé
mais je le répète et je le répète et je
le répète les pour un smartphone à 199
euros 90
c'est normal caméra principale 11 mon
choix de l'ultra grand angle alors ça
c'est la caméra de ses filles voilà ça
fera à peu près la fère s'est pas
stabilisé sais pas où est mais ça y est
la caméra principale on vient ensuite
passé sur l' ultra grand-angle c'est pas
dingue mais ça fait quelques petits
souvenirs mais il faut quand même
beaucoup de lumière on zoome avec le x 2
et on sait ça c'est le mode portrait la
gestion documentaire est pas terrible
détourage n'est pas dingue mais il ya un
petit peu de mal derrière avec les
cheveux je suis reparti dans le studio
le rendu n'est pas qualitatif le
détourage est pas mal bon voilà
conditions de faible luminosité des prix
d'autres potes donald trump avec son
petit doigt en l'air et bien voyez il ya
très peu de lumière dans les pièces
c'est assez brute et mais c'est normal
une fois de plus chemise dans un endroit
où il y avait encore moins de lumière
bon ben voilà on va pas grand chose mais
une fois de plus un peu moins de 100
euros c'est normal la mode macro est
assez cohérent pour le coup avec le
reste vu coller sur une caméra de 2
mégapixels en règle générale je suis pas
très fan mais vu que la qualité ailleurs
n'est pas non plus complètement dingue
mais voyez ça reste relativement
cohérent on voit bien les nervures c'est
pas ou fille sim mais vu ce qu'on peut
sentir que ce smartphone façon un peu
général et bien sera comptable un
smartphone qui peut accueillir une
double carte nanocyl si vous êtes
frontaliers vous avez un abonnement
professionnels particuliers ou si vous
voulez juste avoir de carte pour le
plaisir d'avoir de cartes et bien vous
pouvez la voir
et en plus vous pouvez avoir votre carte
d'extension de mémoire dont vous avez
trois slots et ça c'est cool vous avez
du nfc pour le paiement dématérialisé
aussi c'est un très bon point vous avez
de l'infrarouge grâce à ce tout petit
point avant donc vous allez pouvoir
commander votre télé tous vos appareils
qui sont pilotables en infrarouge c'est
l'appareil permettra de faire beaucoup
de choses que ce soit du vice
naj contrôle et piloter payer partager
énormément de choses c'est très bien et
tout ça à moins de 200 euros autant dire
que chez home une fois de plus a mis la
barre très très haut sur ce smartphone
est un smartphone soit qu'il va falloir
vraiment compté en 2020 on va voir aussi
ce qui se passe du côté du modèle pro
d'ici quelques jours donc si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas invite à vous abonner
dès maintenant un smartphone qui par
contre n'a aucune certification contre
les éclaboussures contre la poussière
c'est aussi normal dans cette gamme de
tarifs là puisqu'il faut chercher à
desceller prix plutôt qu à les augmenter
tout en sachant qu'une certification
pour l'étanchéité de vos smartphones
augmenterait le prix de ce produit
donc bon voilà je ne suis pas sûr non
plus que vous ayez des problèmes si vous
allez rencontrer quelques gouttes d'eau
évitez par contre de le jeter dans
l'évier dans la piscine où vous voulez
mais sinon ça veut quand même plutôt
bien se passer à savoir que je vous le
disais nous avions deux configurations 3
giga de ram 64 giga de stockage 4 gigas
de ram 128 go de stockage mois la config
dont je vous parle aujourd'hui c'est
celle là c'est le 3 + 64 que vous pouvez
retrouver au tarif de tout est écrit ici
va sûrement jeter un oeil
on est à 199 euros 90 et c'est ça qui
est vraiment intéressant c'est le fait
de se dire qu'il nous propose un
smartphone qui va pas être la meilleure
bête de compet va pas avoir le meilleur
écran mais qui par contre ne vous
lâchera pas puisqu'il est autonome vous
permettra de faire beaucoup de choses
donc c'est un smartphone qui en
précommande dès aujourd'hui s'il vous
intéresse vous avez un accessoire offert
vous avez les liens en bas dans la
description pour les jeter un petit coup
d'oeil a vous de me dire vous maintenant
ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
smartphones de chiots me l'année
dernière et notamment des smartphones de
la gamme rewmi note
et est ce que serait notre 9 vous parle
est-ce qu'il vous fait de l'oeil
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter marque va tous ordres en
commentaire je donne rendez vous
extrêmement rapidement pour continuer à
parler de cette gamme r'n'b note avec
leurs ennemis note neuf pros c'était le
jour voilà on va beaucoup d'amour des
gros becs des gros bisous et à très
petits bisous cardiaque à tout va
[Musique]
m
des mines ont barré dans leurs efforts
[Musique]